make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are continuing
on with the swords of x event this time
we are into part five and we are picking
up with the marauders specifically storm
and i like the way this goes down
initially this kind of thing opens up
with storm meeting with kitty pride who
of course kitty pride is more or less
the leader of the marauders team
and the whole idea with storm is she's
currently struggling with the fact that
she has to basically acquire
her own sword that storm is one that has
to grab one of the swords specifically
a sword from wakanda and this is not
something as easily said
or easily done as it is said right
because kitty quad kind of offers her
aid and storm says no this is something
that i have to do on my own
right and the reason for this is given
to us in a little bit of the history
here in wakanda itself what we're
basically given here is this idea that
in the early days
of wakandan history one of the things
that we're told is that in the early
days of wakanda when vibranium first
showed up there the people didn't really
know what to make of it but they didn't
really know what to make of this great
mound this giant asteroid composed of
vibranium that landed on earth but when
wakandans eventually moved or really
kind of settled in the territory and
started focusing and kind of building
their empire around
vibranium it originated with the
creation of what was called the
skybreaker and this was basically a
sword that was
the first weapon crafted out of
vibranium which basically crushed the
enemies that were going against wakanda
the benefit of this
came in the recognition of the potential
this sword had specifically what
vibranium had
and so wakandans began studying
vibranium more and more and the more
they studied it the more they realized
how unique it was
among other metals across the face of
the earth this led to the desire for
vibranium
which led to countries and so on willing
to pay top dollar to get their hands on
it and by being able to pay or being so
willing to pay
so much money for it this is how wakanda
rose to prominence that because
vibranium was so expensive wakanda used
these resources to fund the building of
their cities they use this money to fund
the
education of its people that kind of
thing it's a pretty genius idea
in terms of how it works but more so
than that the skybreaker is passed on
from chief to chief but more so
and what's really important here is the
skybreaker is kind of a symbol of the
wakandan people right it's their
equivalent of like the holy bible for
for christianity right it's it's their
religious concept
something that you simply just don't
mess with or maybe the cross is
something more it's that's probably a
better example but the long and short of
this is storm basically shows up to
wakanda itself right now t'challa is
kind of about doing t'challa's stuff
doing black panther stuff right he's
just doing his black pantherly duties
and it takes him away from wakanda
temporarily and so she ends up meeting
with shuri and the queen mother and one
of the unspoken things about the
the history of storm here is that as
most of you guys know storm was married
to t'challa at one point in time when he
basically nullified their marriage i
think during the events of avengers
versus x-men but they
really haven't been married ever since
right their relationship was a little
stronger than it used to be and they're
kind of
getting back onto good terms to a degree
but marriage doesn't really seem
anything
that's going to be happening anytime
soon and we get this really succinct
you know kind of explanation here which
is one of the things that i like about
vita ayea is he he explains it in a way
to where it's
really really it's done really clearly
right and really easily when queen
mother asks what in the world's going on
the response with storm is
okay so apocalypse had us four horsemen
they were basically banished to this
place called araco
and they eventually formed an army they
invaded otherworld and by accessing
other world they want to lead this army
into the rest of the multiverse starting
with our universe and kill us all
done the plot to x of swords that's
that's the entire gist of it and it's
cool right this is one of the reasons
why i like it
when there are other tie-ins to jonathan
hickman's story right because a lot of
you guys know
hickman he's an amazing writer i love
him to death right i love the work he
does
but he can sometimes make his stories a
little over confusing in terms of how he
writes and and it's easier when somebody
else kind of looks at it and then just
breaks it down in a more digestible way
right because it's very easy to get kind
of get caught up in everything that
hickman's doing because not everything
gets explained right off the bat so it
kind of leaves you
sort of wondering a little bit but the
cool thing about this is that when
when storm tells them this that this
this is a potential threat to
to the world the response of wakanda is
then will assemble an army right we will
make an army and we will we will
help you fight alongside this battle and
storm's idea is no i can't necessarily
do that i need a weapon
specifically a weapon from wakanda one
with history and so that's when you
start getting things like the nation
maker the panther clause the king's
mercy right these different swords that
black panther are different weapons of
black panther have used
over the course of the entire history of
wakanda but storm yet again
turns this down and says no i need the
skybreaker and that's when the response
is
that's not possible that's not something
that we can just give you right we can't
just
hand you this weapon over it could lead
to the disaster our people would riot
right because it would be wakanda giving
away
its most religious figure that more more
and it's kind of interesting the more
that marvel covers the history of
wakanda the more they involve wakanda
and and the rest of the goings-on and
crossovers and whatnot the more you
learn about wakanda's culture and so we
get this explanation here
that because the skybreaker is such an
important figure
in the history of wakanda right it was
the weapon that was used to solidify the
wakandan nature that it's not something
you just
give a person right it's like the
declaration of independence or the
united states constitution you don't
just
hand it over to somebody else right this
is something that you keep protected
under lock and key and that the belief
the faith of the wakandan people
is so revered in terms of this
skybreaker sword that if the wakandan
royal family were to simply give it to
somebody
people would revolt and so the ultimate
statement of storm is i can't have any
sword but that but you know where queen
mother says you know simply wait for
black panther to return right wait for
the total to return
plead your case to him and he will be
the one to make the final decision until
then
you're welcome to stay here as an
honored guest and storm of course
accepts now at that point we switch over
to her private quarters which looks like
it has an amazing view and then she of
course is met by shuri now this is
something that marvel doesn't really
discuss
too much and it kind of sucks because
seeing it now is really cool with storm
being the wife of black panther at one
point in time the wife of t'challa we
never really got a lot of exploration
in terms of her relationship with shuri
it's one of these things where the
relationship between them is that
they're very much sisters
right and they're very close to each
other they have a lot of history there
and it wasn't necessarily history
insofar storm's involvement outside of
black panther it was simply that she was
married to him and the two of them kind
of spent time together right when shuri
became the black panther in the
aftermath of t'challa stepping down
prior to the events of doom war
storm didn't really seem to have a lot
of involvement in shuri's time as black
panther but that didn't necessarily take
away
from from shuri's perception of her a
lot of that was really more because
shuri didn't want anybody else involved
right i mean even with black panther she
took its counsel lightly she wanted to
kind of prove herself right that she
could do it on her own that's kind of
what she was shooting for
ultimately ended up costing her her life
but nonetheless
you know i guess better to go down into
that circumstance than any other but the
the the
important thing is they have this kind
of conversation and she again kind of
reiterates this position
there are people in wakanda who are
literally just looking for a reason to
get rid of us
right every single day they're looking
for a reason to oust us because they
consider us to be too forward thinking
too progressive that we're not
you know really kind of latched down and
allowing ourselves to be held back
by tradition right we're not living in
the past essentially and so if we were
to give you this sword they would use
that as a reason to create revolt and
not even my mother the queen mother and
not even t'challa would be able to talk
these individuals down that a revolt
would inevitably happen could we quash
it yes but it would cost lives in the
process but the ultimate result of this
is they end up hitting a stalemate
that shuri doesn't really side with
storm and say okay fine we'll find a way
in for you but storm doesn't really ally
with shuri and say yeah you're right it
really is too much to ask
i should be on my way instead it's just
kind of like you know wait for t'challa
to get here and storm's idea is
i can't right i can't wait for this and
so she ends up of course
donning her x-men uniform and then
taking to the skies in wakanda now at
this point we kind of get a little bit
of an explanation in terms of what this
whole deal is right and it sort of
bounces back and forth
between what storm's doing at the moment
and what's happening now because you can
obviously tell what storm's doing let's
kind of went over this history a little
bit while you guys are checking that out
but the idea is that
the temple of the heart of wakanda is
kind of like its most revered place
right it's this most sacred place
i don't recall if this runs part and
parcel with a necropolis but the point
is is that black panther t'challa
basically says
the sword itself is a symbol of the
spirit of wakanda right it's what it
means to be a wakandan and it is
never ever ever to be taken from
wakandan soil right it's like taking the
heart of the country the heart of the
nation you just don't do it right that
if you take that it would be like
killing wakanda right
more so than that as as as black panther
takes her through there's tata
you know t'challa took her through there
this of course happened back during the
days of civil war basically the civil
war event at least we assume it does
right because that's when they got
married
that t'challa says like if you're going
to be my wife it's important that you
understand the true history and culture
of wakanda but notice this one of the
things that t'challa does is he doesn't
tell her everything but what he says is
that here
this facility is under surveillance 24
hours
by priests and so while storm's able to
use her power over weather to create
lightning that'll take down power to the
place and it takes about 30 minutes for
it to reboot that there are still analog
security here right there's there's
still guys there's still people walking
around now understand
these guys know how to fight they're
able to kind of fight back right there
they use they need more than like well
they're able to do more than like use
guns
essentially that these guys are trained
as some of the most prodigious fighters
in all of i'm sorry in in the marvel
universe right on earth so they're there
to protect the sword breaker of what use
would they be if they were not highly
prodigious fighters but as good as they
are
storm is better now this is also partly
because she's able to get the upper hand
and sneak up on them but even with the
knock down drag out fight between the
two
storm's able to overcome and this comes
from a variety of different sources
right it comes from storm's
storm's youth where she would talk was
taught how to fight during her time as a
thief it comes from storm's time on the
x-men when she was the wife of black
panther and was taught various forms of
martial arts by some of his best
fighters the dora malaysia these are the
kind of things that were where she
gained her experience from right so she
really is
a highly prodigious fighter the problem
with this is that once she
accesses this it acts as a skybreaker
with the intention of replacing it with
a with a fake sword
that before she can grab it the fake
sword's blown out of her hand and the
reason why
is because shuri's there and shuri
suspected this is exactly what storm
would do that storm would take this need
and she would say i cannot wait
i cannot wait for t'challa to get here
or anything along those lines now the
fight between the two
is pretty intriguing and one of the
things to easily overlook about shuri is
how good she is at fighting if she was
going to become the black panther
she had to first and foremost be the
leader of her armies right to be the
commander
of all the wakandan armies and nobody
none of the members of the wakandan army
would respect
a black panther who couldn't fight but
the idea here is that the two of them
are
able to fight pretty closely now one
thing to bear in mind is that storm is
not really looking to kill shuri if she
was
she would just shut her down entirely
using her powers but again because
sheree has been black panther she's one
of the best fighters in all of wakanda
and easily on par with storm and so kind
of going back and forth you end up
having shuri who manages to overtake
storm and then says like this is it i'm
going to take you with me to the palace
and together we're going to speak with
t'challa right so notice this shuri's
response isn't i'm taking you back to
the palace and we're going to throw you
in jail because you obviously tried to
steal from us there's still respect
there there's still love and kindness
there right she's not seeing her as
somebody who betrayed wakanda even if
it's true
because the the case of storm is so
extreme and sure he knows that storm
would not absolutely do this unless she
felt like she had no other choice right
that's what we're kind of looking at
here but storm
ultimately ends up overing power shuri
and then replacing the sword with a fake
one and then effectively leaving but as
soon as she does
she's met by the arrival of t'challa
right t'challa immediately shows up and
says
why are you doing this right now
t'challa shows up here with his personal
guard
these guys are not to be trifled with
these guys and the dora melashe
all t'challa has to do is just like give
her give the thumbs down or just say
take her and like they will overpower
her right like they will they will over
overpower her before she can use her
powers that's how good these guys are
they are wildly capable now storm is
super powerful
she is omega level but also keep in mind
black panther
knows how to neutralize his wife if this
was anybody else storm would overcome
them and that would be the end of it but
being married to her and knowing her as
he does
it would not take long for black panther
to take her down right that's just kind
of the way that is and that's one of the
things where he says like why would you
do this
like i would have done this like if you
had asked me i would have given you this
sword
like my you know queen mother told me
everything that's going on if you had
asked i would have given you this
all you had to do was just wait and
that's where it really kind of breaks
down the relationship between the two
because ultimately
they don't trust each other and that's
the biggest problem that sure black
panther trusts her insofar as he would
have given her this but ultimately storm
doesn't trust
him right she doesn't trust that he
would have given her this weapon and
knowing you know in
the whole time knowing what discourse or
what kind of discord
it might cause among his people she
didn't trust him on that and rightfully
so right because black panther has
consistently made himself a guy
who would put his people first and so it
doesn't really make a whole lot of sense
that in the face of all that
consistently kind of maintaining that
position that he would suddenly
change his mind and not only change his
mind give her the most symbolic weapon
of his people right it doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense that he would
suddenly do that but ultimately he just
ends up letting her leave
and the reason why is because she says
if i do not leave here with this sword
we are all going to die right like
understand i would not do this unless i
absolutely have to you know me you are
married to me you know the kind of
person that i am the fact that i would
come here
and i would defy the request of your
mother to wait until you return even if
it only would have been a couple hours
for the purpose of going in there and
stealing your most sacred weapon
and leaving you have to know that it's a
serious deal and that's when he says
let her go but in response he says
destroy the gate right destroy the
the krakowin gate like krakowa has lost
its ability to kind of
sneak in and out as they see fit right
there was a measure of trust that's been
lost here and so if cohen's if mutants
are going to come back here then they're
going to come back here through the
normal channels they're going to request
that we allow them in we will either
honor or deny that request and then
we'll meet them as we would any
ambassador from any other country
anywhere in the world
storm you lost that privilege no more
special rights for you right no more
special privileges for you and so storm
ultimately ends up making her way back
to gracoa she takes her place on the uh
on the the panel alongside
magic and wolverine and that's where we
are right and that brings an end to this
story so
i think it's good but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
in this town
[Music]
oh
[Music]
this
you